we say a lot of complimentary things
about you on the show because you're
very good at your job thanks a million
yes you are I appreciate it among a
bunch of Great Moments in that hallway
scene there is an extra little one which
is when you're done with the speech you
are trying to figure out a way how you
cannot turn around and you're so Furious
about the fact that you do have to turn
around and no you've got these squeaky
shoes
she's made her speech which has
ostensibly gone well
then she knows she has to walk through
Dudu Kaka
to get out of there it's a profound
humiliation that moment yeah we like to
compliment you don't let go to your head
I didn't write the squeaky shoes dumbass
he was being humble I was being humble
because they really did write that and
then you know all of a sudden it's like
oh wow